editor of the people are aware that
there would be these at the end of the
people's republic your learn midterm
year after birth and org
requested that they would prefer if you
have direct replies internees
occurred
i've got a lot
at halftime
or credit
to bear this out of europe
foreseen
archive
contract
between conditions
in china today and those conditions like
target american
uh... along with him
i would be
sending that kind of
general economic level
is now that i've been arrested
like intergroup wat
on the uh... commuting you can call
instrument out there
civic uh...
juggling homeboy
thank you don't want to know
to do that
no we didn't i don't know
it cannot be dead
holcomb national economy achieve all
around
applicant
just with the work of readjustment again
the main
incompletes
the apple cart rock put it this year
well attack
mentioned at the end of the first by via
fax
output of great cochran tick
as compared with last year
display industry
great progress has been made
ali enviar
but also in the variety
and quality of the product
adequately staffed
for them all-round beat
forward who's been made
industry treatment
incline toxicology cra quoted users who
could make quite a remarkable double
you can see it but i can be achieved
encontrar defeated website query wanting
a crock
development anyway
a lot going on there
yuki torii
act for market replied right
nothing
but they didn't have at least
are plentiful
compatibility diligent to seek the
supply of cotton
but the growth of copper
profession over the past three years
through several provided by the
blueprint possibility tentatively agreed
to be output of quality
sort of thing that i am
you know that the production of chemical
fibres
it's also increased go up
we are confident
but in the parts of the third five-year
plan
or the fire causing for the people
for further rock
johnson
pool with the palestinian people
drive through deliveries
national economy uniquely his wound up
an all-round prop
all-around broke
will be conclusive
front officer
agricultural production next year
past also made a quick break
for the third ideapad
it was uh...
them
national people's congress
him
polly
i wonder if you could give me
indication of the main point
owner and real bad there
to blue was congress
uh... ended december thirty first
if what you get breakfast but they're
actual people outburst
on behalf of the government
i'd help make your point
for the national people's congress
october if applicable
across properly ives
a palm tree pollen react
socialist obstruction
sofas promotion
international pressure
views view and up
uh...
secondly who do you think it would be
under present circumstances
to have some exchange of savage
when they'll be here
around bangalore down throughout
got delayed by if they're going to be
peaceful
uh... intervention
in order for him to rule that
vital american relations
that we must start
with microsoft
and left with five issue
effort by the american ambassador or
often walks off
we always put forward
the follies coupons of principle
is that if we can
should be reached
decline of the united states not
peaceful coexistence
on the picket
after five
and the other
but the united states
must withdraw all of you cough
crosses by law
and the taiwan strait
one
can be reached on teens end point of
principle
other questions itself rather heated
gilded
and a lot to do it
the mir heckling
your applied equally what i thought the
fundamental problem
for one thought popped up for anything
going on for more than nine years
out-of-state all along with you
look weak
a peaceful quiet the principal
united faith
follows another something
the people
is for people called it
upon a time of course for it
the united states refuse it
doesn't disprove
hypocrisy of the work of the u_s_
government
if the question of the text which are
not type of individuals
melodramatic thoughtful
at the present time either
thoughtful we welcome
the u_s_ government won't allow for calm
alcohol what was going to find out
artwork on file
like that
vicki their work
questions up
print the bloodbath battles u_s_
aircraft locking up at least
uh... plan expected
we welcome your anyway fifty-five
recently for medical com
and
the circumstances
indication
united
papers creation
independent
taiwan
which seemed to
removed the possibility
perhaps for many years
normalization of sino-american
hopefully david keene area
when you're out
in his uh... without the right now
here but i
at the fact that product on attract
extra peacock off
claims represent china
uh... cost
alpha kappa connie cadre with that
there should be from walk i won't
we thought would be to create
exetel com three full equality
and ralph deep pockets
uh...
accepted me
off u_s_ quality
antiquarian pallav
will be a folk rock
politically humans
rely on for the majority occupational
under that magic they can't portion of
the what's problematic
contribute for you settle china's lawful
speaking applications
i can tell you frankly
backed by all the
what the impossible couldn't prove it
at one o'clock panel event
aquatic more
lookup nothing
whatsoever
well with the united nations
socket situation
should arrive helpful
uh... panel american confrontation
we would not be a question
of a few years
it'll be a bit longer rachel
of we don't know
how many years
during my about what it really came
through the great copy an affidavit will
cost
out-of-state are built up so i won't be
able to come to know what the staff
and gives up the property
uh... rapidly number of nations that
uh...
restoring balance sheet
and the u_n_
increasing
one more nations now maintain relations
with china
may be that there is a majority already
uh... paper
seating chart a new web
do you expect to see you
uh... chuan keat restored this year
no doubt that is in the presentation
like printout
work with
are all
uh...
why don't they aren't foul
fifty countries
africanized up at diplomatic relations
with us
and the number of perhaps eat bread
equipment i think we'll be able to deal
with various methods
who obstruct the restoration of politics
that's right
united nations
and prevent
the expulsion of the catholic church big
operations
the fourth and i'm not trying to get
expected here
uh...
thank you
sino-american relations
are judging from reports published
abroad
john bomb went for much more
sophisticated nature then america next
anticipated
when it would be possible for you to
comment on
just what it meant
in terms of china's technological and
scientific engineering
uh... development
that's our goal or
recruitment buried the
concludes there
so they're all thought that
may but it turned out
uh... connecting with uh...
have come to the conclusion
from the date that they collected
technical level of data bawi exploded
it's hot
of the first nuclear test
but the united states
predominate contract
look on this laptop with me
uh... american express
debt
e bal more valuable
with that
or perhaps
or from what i do
may order of the proposed outfit light
up at all
that part
tension and southeast
especially in vietnam laos
he's reaching a critical stage
yeah
wonderful circumstance
child that would render edge these
countries church teachings tended to
north korea
it is a
with reading out of your family
unit linked with the entire those final
question
uh... and it is precisely on the
question affixed and in the water
indochina
but they did not have played market
i think that's always answers below
uh... everywhere
trying to articulate
it's very clear
uh... if the united states should run
rampant the indochina
we will definitely not i'd really hot
you're not a single
hectic dot the korean war before going
to walk away decreed outlawing indochina
didn't know what will happen
but there is no floppy
therefore the exact date
uh... mayo quite difficult
without at a few uh... simply throughout
published
wud
however the u_s_ government
often doesn't believe the state
uh... but always being
the top of the statement dot one thing
and
what we actually going to end into it's
another
united states is always anxious to get
tough
inside information
thinking that only ten and if i dont
artistic exactly different understaffed
throughout the for many years of the
founder of the people of public a plan
upto
every word was spoken house
we meet what we say
i like them
we don't practice double techniques
three and one thing file to another
afterthought the state where responsible
for the chinese people responsible
people of all were ultimately we hit it
off while works of art
i hope you have time for you
cannot solve it
would be
simpson fallout
uh... the china still in place
that uh... so we can you should not
participate in the next afro asian
counsel
or enough that we do india almost
king any potential with regard to the
what army acclimation conference
we friendlier five albeit renewed needs
to be prepared for a meeting protected
if you happen to conference
held out for april
iraq
at that meeting
acting depend on conference
unanimity atrophied she before it's an
entire any question for the week
ask for those questions with the
majority of the property political
cannot approval while football equipment
could be reached
there was the first time
the proposal reaching agreement more
unanimity
and became common ground content of this
office i think the battlefield public
knowledge
but they cannot be trusted
these principles what once again fearful
chicago territory meeting
i have one hundred other questions but i
think i will consumed all that pat
buchanan three allotted man
and i want much or
right back
what ended
hand-painted narrowed it down